yeah Jason Momoa Bears it all on the
deep blue sea the Aquaman star gets
cheeky during a fishing trip with
friends here he is focusing on reeling
in a catch while what's catching our
focus is that beige thong-like covering
he's wearing mostly because it leaves
little to the imagination
[Music]
wow
oh wow so beautiful
[Music]
yep Jason's booty is out as he and his
friend reel in some booty of their own a
massive tuna awesome the actor's bare
butt matches his sort of bear head last
month Jason who's known for his
signature do shaved off part of his Mane
so
shaving off the hair
oh man
I've never even felt the wind right
there
and he revealed his new look was all in
an effort to raise awareness
do it for uh
single-use Plastics
I'm tired of these plastic bottles
things in our ocean it's just so sad so
please
anything you can do
to eliminate single-use Plastics in your
lives
help me a couple weeks later Jason
debuted his brand new head tattoo I got
something pretty something special for
you
shoot super War coming baby
yup the actor was off to film his latest
project a new Apple TV plus series chief
of War it goes to New Zealand finally
again it's been like two years since uh
since they were able to go because of
covet but before we get eyes on that
we'll see Jason and his intact long
locks in the upcoming Aquaman sequel
Aquaman and the lost kingdom
about to fix my ass
I'm super excited to be back making the
sequel I have so much invested into it I
love this character I love what it
represents it just laughs I I I've never
uh me and Patrick it's it's a it's a bit
of a Brother's journey and so uh it's a
lot of funny stuff and there's a lot of
stuff that's just what's going on in our
environment talking about climate change
and just hitting on certain things that
I wanted to hit on and
um yeah it's just a lot of laughs and
also a lot of pain so just wonderful
action
gonna be a fun adventure like it was the
first time just better
[Music]